[Musique]
les cosmonautes shadoks continuent leur
vol d'essai sous la direction technique
du devin plombier il travaillait dans
l'étroite collaboration mais on voyait
bien que ça risquait de durer
le marin shadoks qui regardaient ça
disait même que la fusée ne partirai
jamais c'était un ancien quartier maître
pirate qui avait mal tourné
contrairement aux gens de son espèce qui
passe généralement leur tend à
introduire des petits bateaux dans une
bouteille
lui il a introduisait des bouteilles
dans son petit bateau il parlait par
maxime et quelquefois même en anglais
c'est lui qui disait par exemple dans la
marine
on ne fait pas grand chose mais on le
fait de bonheur et en effet il partait
dès potron minet soi disant pour aller
voir où était le vent mais le soir quand
il revenait il avait complètement oublié
il disait qu'il était saoul influent en
réalité il était tout simplement pris de
boisson pour la fusée il disait que le
plus simple était encore d'aller
subtilisé la fusée jbe que lui
connaissait le chemin et que lui il
irait l'a subtilisé lui et en bateau
actuellement c'était insensé mais comme
il était un peu trop souvent sous
l'influencé qu'ils constituaient un
objet de scandale
le chef shadoks lui donna quand même
l'autorisation
en fait il se disait que c'était un
moyen simple et les gants de s'en
débarrasser le pauvre marin pourrait-il
tenir son pari et traverser le cosmos en
bateau
[Musique]